partout au québec derrière chaque
fenêtre du ch est celle des hérons il y
a une histoire un héritage
la famille d'antonietta police vient
chaque jour ici avec l'espoir de voir la
doyenne de 97 ans apparaître quelques
minutes à sa fenêtre à travers les
sourires se cache l'angoissent nous
sommes inquiètes pour la mer aussi parce
que ça semble être déshydraté et et
c'est pas bon pour sa santé dans à
manger en retard
c'est pas toujours le temps qu'ils
devaient être ils sont pas là pour elle
pour ses soins depuis qu'ils ont pris
charge plus ça ne semble pas savoir
améliorer et on a tous beaucoup de
questions on atteint il cache cache
beaucoup et pour moi c'est une façon de
fonctionner avec des anges et parmi les
nombreux morts ici le père de frédéric
girard décédé la semaine dernière
derrière ces murs de la kfw 19
on n'a pas pu venir l'aider et l'appuyer
le tenir la main me dire qu'on le maire
c'est très difficile saissac et du set
très difficile
j'espère que le personnage un renvoi
vers m'ont dit non parce que mory comme
ça sans dénis désert c'est cruel
des histoires comme celle du papa de
frédéric girard il y en a des centaines
au québec
la mère de peter weir l'inde a été
transféré vendredi soir à l'hôpital
malgré plusieurs symptômes reliés au
virus la direction du sus de l'ouest de
l'île de montréal aurait refusé de lui
faire passer un test au niveau de
communication c'était pire avec le cir
explicité avec les résidences privées
parce qu'on n'avait aucune information
on n'a pas personnaliser qu'il y avait
tellement de monde en bâtisse il déplore
aussi le mauvais traitement que sa mère
aurait reçu ma mère était elle avait des
coachs plein puis aussi il avait son son
sac de rennes c'était tellement
discipline que ça éclate est restée sur
le plancher peter willen a perdu son
père la semaine dernière can willen un
homme de famille est mort de la kfw 19
aussi h et celle des de la salle il ya
des gens qui ont besoin dun qui reçoit
pas de dead qui vont qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie au québec y contribuer à
bâtir la société puisse être entraîneur
en train de mourir sauf mon père mon
père était un homme très généreux qui
est toujours assez d aider des gens qui
avaient besoin alors en suisse on son
modèle ici marie michel lauzon
radio-canada à montréal